Sarah Jacobs I I had not heard of her
before this she is a backbencher
Democrat Congressman I guess she has
some interesting theories on state power
and biology 24 states have banned
abortion or are likely to do so
without Roe Americans are now facing a
confusing Patchwork of state laws
dictating who can make decisions about
their health care and when
without Roe state governments are
forcing pregnancy on people the state
governments are forcing pregnancy how
are they doing that what'd you say well
because they ban abortion how does Sarah
Jacobs think that pregnancy begins when
a man and a woman love each other very
much
they go out they get married then they
do this thing and then that's that's how
you get a baby now of course it involves
catalogs of people and hundreds of
thousands of dollars in test tubes and
all sorts of weird Canadian laws and but
previously that was how but under no
circumstances
does the state Force somebody to become
pregnant